hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of modeling the masters
I believe that the fastest and most
effective way to very business is some
model the strategies of people who've
already done what you're trying to do so
today we're gonna look at how a high
school dropout went from being a
complete failure at school to being one
of the most recognized faces on
television and being a super successful
entertainment entrepreneur this is a
story of Simon Cowell and the top three
lessons that you can learn from his
success Simon Cowell group and Elstree
Hertfordshire with his three
half-brothers a half-sister as well as a
brother and a sister
his father Eric was a successful real
estate agent as well as an executive in
the music industry
well his mother Julie was known
throughout town as a socialite largely
raised by nannies Cowell and his brother
were sent off to boarding school and
were frequently transferred for their
misconduct by the time Cowell will just
16 years old he had already been a
registered student at 16 different
schools
Kyle would never graduate from any of
those 16 schools he attended over the
years in 1979 he got his first job
working as a mailroom clerk for EMI
Music Publishing thanks to his father's
connections in many ways I was glad I'd
started my career on the very low rung
of the business Kyle recalls it was
there that I learned how to deal with
people over the next few years
Kyle would work his way up within the
ranks of the company to eventually
become a record producer unsatisfied
with his prospects Cowell left EMI in
the early 1980s to form E and s music
with his own independent music company
after his achievements in the music
industry
Cowell turned his attention next to
reality TV he'd witnessed a huge success
of the show pop stars and was determined
to take advantage of what he saw as the
rising trend in 2001 Cowell teamed up
with producer Simon Fuller to create Pop
Idol where audiences would vote in a
national talent search for a pop singer
Cowell himself was one of the panel
judges whose brutally honest criticisms
soon became the show's
attraction today cowl is considered one
of the most successful reality TV
creators in the world and is worth more
than 320 million dollars making more
than 75 million dollars annually in
salary from television shows and music
producing by starting at the bottom I'm
by working hard to achieve his goals
Simon Cowell is able to go from a high
school dropout one of the most
successful people in the entertainment
business to help you achieve your goals
here are top three lessons that you can
learn from Simon Cowell
action item number 1 don't compromise as
an entrepreneur you're gonna have a lot
of people tell you that the way you want
to do something will never work and you
should take a different approach or
worse quit if you have a vision for how
you see things working out stick to it
listen to what others have to say and
take some of it under consideration
but don't let negative people prevent
you from doing what you set out to do
Simon Cowell is all business he refuses
to back down in the face of criticism
and opposition and does not let personal
feelings get in the way of his work
after Cowell had made particularly harsh
comments toward a contestant family
members of that rejected contestant were
waiting for Cowell with baseball bats
ready to beat him up in typical Calif
action he just laughed it off and used a
different exit it wasn't gonna change
anything for him
he continues to speak his mind and as a
self-proclaimed entrepreneur he does not
compromise
according to Cowell I haven't done
anything particularly harsh harshness to
me has given somebody false hopes and
not following through that's harsh
telling some guy or some girl we've got
zero talent that they have zero talent
actually is a kindness I think you have
to judge everything based on your
personal tastes and if that means being
critical so be it I hate political
correctness I absolutely loathe it I've
always treated the music business as a
business whether I'm making TV shows or
signing artists you have to do it by the
head and not the heart and I run my
business that way
action item number two don't fear
rejection you're gonna hear a lot of
nose as you build your business some
will likely even come from people you
thought you could count on
don't let rejections hold you back some
people will say no and that's their loss
know in your heart that there is someone
out there who wants to say yes and don't
give up until you find them throw out
his career cow would become quite
familiar with rejection after he was
initially expelled from numerous
boarding schools Cowell could have
easily given up
Headmaster's were not only telling
Cowell that there was no place for him
in their schools but that there was no
place for him in a civilized society
that's a hard message a swallow as a
young boy however Cowell wanted to prove
them wrong
even in his first businesses he would
face rejection and have to rebuild after
losing everything Cowell has learned
that little failures along the way are
what make for a great success in the end
being rejected is going to happen at
some time in your life it is what you do
next after being rejected that makes a
difference according to Cowell work hard
be patient and be a sponge while
learning your business learn how to take
criticism follow your gut instincts and
don't compromise
not everybody is perfect and I don't
think we should be looking for perfect
people in the music business over the
last 25 years I faced a lot of rejection
it's a lesson learned you have to stand
out from the crowd
action on number three trust your gut
you never have enough information to
make a completely informed decision by
the time you get all the data it's too
late to act you have missed the
opportunity instead learn to get as much
details as you can to make a decision
and trust your gut you'll make some
mistakes but that's part of business and
you'll be better equipped to handle the
next big decision it's better to take
action get it wrong and course-correct
then to take no action at all and miss
out when Carol first started out at BMG
he wanted more than anything to produce
a hit and proved himself to be a
valuable contribution to the company
after years of rejection by the industry
oddly enough he decided to look in the
direction of professional wrestling his
colleagues thought he was crazy but
Cowell had a hunch that a young boy
should pay to watch professional
wrestling and buy all the related
merchandise they would also buy a WWF
themed record sung by the superstar
wrestlers themselves cowls hunch was
right on the mark the WWF superstars
album was an instant smash hit after
that few would doubt Cowell's instincts
he would later go on to record albums
with the Power Rangers and the
Teletubbies both of which achieved
similar levels of success when most
people had dismissed opera as not being
mainstream Cal mix it with pop and for
attractive young men and create an
instant mainstream success where few
people thought was any potential for a
successful record Cowell followed his
instincts according the qaol when I was
30 the company that owned fanfare went
bust and I effectively lost everything I
had to move in with my parents in
hindsight it was the best thing that
happened in my life because I learned
the value of money not to borrow money
and not to live beyond my means and I
learned that getting there is more fun
than being there but one thing that I've
always been able to do is own up to my
mistakes and not blame others
I can't bear political correctness I
don't like a rule driven life and I hate
the fact that you can't criticize a fat
person
so remember don't compromise don't fear
rejection and trust your gut to finish
up this video I wanted to share one of
my favorite true stories about Simon
Cowell and some of his best quotes Simon
Cowell is known best for his honest
sometimes rude comments he makes it
contestants on his reality television
shows however most people did not know
that he starts out every morning the
same way
Cowell calls his assistant each morning
with the time he wants breakfast he hits
a snooze button after making the call
two more times once he has hit the
snooze button for the second time his
assistant starts to bring in his
breakfast which has been the same for
the last five years he starts up the day
with hot water with lemon then drinks
papaya juice with a little lime after
that he is brought a bowl of oatmeal
then drinks a cup of tea once he's
finished all of this he has a spinach
smoothie antioxidant smoothie and
finishes his breakfast routine with a
seven fruit smoothie after finishing
this complicated breakfast routine this
man that everyone thinks is one of the
harshest men in television always turns
on the TV to watch cartoons while having
an IV drip of multiple vitamins he was
afraid of needles as a boy so this tough
acting man has to have his arm frozen
with a spray to have the procedure
performed the reason he has such an
unusual morning routine because he plans
to live forever saying if I don't do it
I could regret this in 300 years time
thank you for joining me for another
edition of my Linda masters if you like
the video you want to see more please
give it a thumbs up below I'd also love
to hear what you have to think if you
want to leave a comment under the video
or if you have a question please leave a
comment below and we'll see you on the
next episode
you